welcome back earth day is thursday and
subaru of las vegas is all about
protecting our environment
[Music]
you can do a lot of things to help the
environment maybe plant a garden
perhaps grow a subaru
[Music]
alright a little sun and i uh i should
probably get out of the way
it worked this is amazing it worked
all right that's a little tv magic but
here at subaru of las vegas they're
doing some great things to help the
planet it's burton hughes general
manager of subaru of las vegas good to
see you
good to see you jc and hey we're getting
low on inventory i need you to grow some
more cars like that i'll get on it i can
grow some more
burton a couple of things about subaru
of las vegas one you guys love the
planet
two is you love your customers what are
some of the things that you guys are
doing to help preserve the environment
you know obviously uh we are definitely
in love with our planet
as you can see love our national parks
subaru is the
largest single corporate donor for the
national park foundation
and we just like getting out there and
doing stuff in our community that helps
preserve it
burton i feel like i'm saving the
environment just sitting inside of a
subaru forester
yeah you know subaru for for years and
years they've been focused on the
environment
by building partial zero emission
vehicles this is one of them
the exhaust fumes coming out are cleaner
than the air you breathe in downtown los
angeles
wow and does this have the special start
stop feature on that what
how does that work it does so the stop
start is amazing you come to a stop
you have your foot on the brake the
engine quietly just silence goes it goes
dead it's
it's silent and then when you lift your
foot off the brake the engine starts up
and you take off
and it saves gas it saves emissions it's
amazing you're
so when you're sitting in that bumper to
bumper traffic on the 15 or 215 you're
saving the environment because the
thing's going to turn off
absolutely now talk to me about the
engine size because we've gone with a
smaller engine but it still has a lot of
power
it does subaru has gone from some of the
models having six cylinder engines and
they've reduced that to four cylinder
with turbochargers
you have you still have the power but
you have lower emissions and and higher
fuel mileage
i could see myself driving this thing
across the country maybe through
yellowstone park this summer it's it's a
beautiful car
now there's something here at the
dealership i've always wanted to see you
a very special fish tank
350 gallons of salt water and we've got
we have an eel in there we've got a
little mini shark it's amazing
what happens if you open the door that's
what we scare the kids with but no
it doesn't it doesn't all come out let's
talk about earth day i know you guys
have a lot of special things planned
what are you planning for earth day so
this thursday
subaru of las vegas and get outdoors
nevada we're going to be at exploration
peak park
and we're going to be cleaning up the
trails and cleaning up the park it's
going to be a lot of fun
then on sunday we're going to do
something really fun
right out here in front of the
dealership we're going to clear out all
the cars and from 10 a.m
to 2 p.m we're gonna have an earth day
farmer's market
and we've invited a whole bunch of
people to be here
to to bring their wares and their food
and all that fun stuff
at farmer's market's going to be awesome
on sunday call subaru of las vegas at
702
495 or find them online at subaru of las
vegas dot com
and remember their special offer subaru
love strikes twice
certified pre-owned event happening now
through april 30th
zero percent apr financing on select
2021 models
for well-qualified buyers las vegas now
we will be
right back